all right this is the milk crate
challenge oh these are hilarious you've
seen this so it's like people stack up
milk crates and they're doing the
challenge and they're getting yeah it's
insanely dangerous i don't know why
they're doing why people are doing this
i know it doesn't make any sense
with this
who for what like i don't get
olympics it's fantastic did you see
bradley martin do it no he did it with
dumbbells and all the way up to the
table yeah yeah i think i saw that yeah
it's on his instagram so now what is the
challenge here i'll just play for your
bro you'll see you've got to stack them
like that and walk them and they can
support 50 pounds
so this is a successful one the
successful ones aren't fun
hey she don't know what the [__]
what's she supposed to do she's just
trying to walk over and get down yeah
without falling like this like this
so she did it boom
they're all crunk
go to some of the bloopers people are
breaking their arms yeah people are
[__] themselves up watch this
hold on
here's some jordan ones on tide
i ain't holding on for [__]
so you gotta time it
know they're trying to go around each
other
lead them along someone said just take
your time
nobody's rushing y'all
it's like the top of a wedding cake
he hugging the [__] out of mike look at
him
i think i'll do it
that was a good one
oh [__] you definitely don't want to
drink
it might be in this one they're so funny
damn they're so bad it's insane i would
never the wedding cake i would never i
would do it i don't know if the crate
would hold my big ass though
all right hold on they were hyped for
him he headed forward
go down chin what's up go down there's
another one
oh this one's insane yeah this one's
like the original oh that's on not good
ground this is the original one oh he's
a [__]
he's like so that's not safe he just no
you hit so hard
this is when you got you're just bored
as [__] my thing is
bad where'd he get all these milk crates
from oh
that was bad that was like i didn't see
it i was looking
you get paralyzed like that uh you can
definitely have a very bad back like
that oh yeah that'll [__] your back
they're fantastic though how much more
entertaining is that than the real
olympics
[__] man god it's great
i feel like you could do it b you're
light-footed you could do it no i'm not
gonna do it i'm a little too old though
cause then if i fall something bad
happens is there any white people doing
it nope apparently martial is the only
one that feels like a white guy thing to
do though yeah that's what i'm saying
i'm like that
no
it's been all black people
because they caught the hood olympics
no they told me yeah they do yeah they
do it yeah they do it's called the crate
challenge not the hood no i'm telling
this is hashtag hood hood olympics damn
where's bradley at here you go oh this
first is one of christians found
oh i saw this one who just turned the
camera around
what's his song
first of all he's barefoot okay
oh
[__] look he's all damn at least it
landed flat
that's that's a better one
yeah
go to bradley i think barefoot's the way
to do it that definitely knocked the
wind that guy could not breathe after
that
i just feel like i'm too big for it
yeah i don't like the prospects of you
falling on that oh i thought he was
doing on weights
who is this bradley martin oh but he's
oh he's the uh guru that's my boy yeah
okay is that zoo culture
all right
oh wow well that's impressive bradley
you got to be careful bradley because
this is exactly how you can break your
[__]
oh boy what are those 25 pound dumbbells
still though no one's done it no no i
wouldn't even try it
i would just throw him to the ground
bradley yeah then she gives him his food
she has some diapers give him food yep
she's beautiful by the way
not that i'm noticing but i'm just
saying that's what you look oh he did
that easily
was he was he an athlete no not not like
an actual athlete but you know like a
hood athlete i think that's what you
would call it
that was pretty easy for him yeah
it's just balance
that's a going on core
core strength
well i just got me all tight right now
could you do it ryan i think brian could
do it easy i mean i can do a good core
strength maybe